okay everybody's sound is good yes yes
okay thank y'all very much for joining
us again today today mayor price is
going to give an initial statements
followed by chief Krauss and will give
an update on the investigation and David
Cook will have a brief statement after
that if y'all would hold your questions
until the end then we will be able to
take some questions of any of the three
that you'd like to ask questions to with
that go ahead and introduce mere price
thank you good afternoon thank you all
for being here we wanted to take this
opportunity to talk a little bit about
Saturday night Saturday morning what
happened
and mrs. Jefferson's death but before
chief and city managers speak I wanted
to say a few things to my city we are
all heartbroken today auntie on it was a
beautiful smart amazing young woman
by all accounts who was unjustly taken
from her family the entire city is in
pain as a mother a grandmother a sister
an ad I can't imagine anything worse and
I'm so sorry
on behalf of the entire city of Fort
Worth I'm sorry - auntie Ana's family
it's unacceptable
there is nothing that could justify what
happened on Saturday morning nothing -
mr. James Smith I know you're hurting
today as well you called police as we
asked good neighbors to do you were
being that wonderful neighbor the one
that we all want next door to us the
type of person who does what's right in
Fort Worth
auntie Ana's death has left you totally
shaken and your sense of security and
trust in law enforcement jeopardized and
I'm sorry - aww - Janos
after you who witnessed the unspeakable
loss sorry doesn't cut it the entire
city needs to surround this young man
with prayer support and anything that
his family needs
lastly the images released showing the
gun inside miss Jefferson's home the gun
is irrelevant she was in her own home
caring for an eight year old nephew aunt
Tiana was a victim she was taken from
her family in circumstances that are
truly unthinkable I'm listening and
hearing our community my home
there's heartbreak but healing and
renewal of trust will come it will take
a significant amount of work from all of
us and it must be done day by day
a step at a time action by action and it
won't stop until we have justice and
closure for our Tiana's family to
rebuild a sense of trust for the
community and with our Police Department
mere words are not enough we are taking
immediate action you will hear from the
chief and city manager in a few moments
city leadership has set in place motions
to bring a third party panel of national
experts to review this department city
manager Cook will have more specifics
for you in a minute
I would say I just Lee love mercy walk
humbly those words from scriptures are
sharp and poignant on a day like today
our community is mourning and hurting
everyone expects justice no matter how
you define justice this council this
city and this Police Department will
live humbly and provide the justice
justice is critical here we know we
cannot bring back this young woman who
was taken all to singing but this is a
pivotal moment for a city
that will and can come together and we
will take actions swiftly and with
transparency
thank you all for caring let's wrap this
family in love and prayers chief Krauss
Thank You mayor before I provide an
update I'd first like to extend my
sincerest sympathies to the family of a
Tatyana Jefferson her father called this
shooting senseless and I certainly have
not been able to make sense of why she
had to lose her life on behalf of the
men and women of the 4th Police
Department I'm so sorry for what
occurred you Tatiana's family and
friends have my apologies my condolences
and my prayers we've received many calls
from the community expressing their
concerns and demands and I assure you as
chief of this department I share those
concerns and I demand a thorough
transparent and speedy investigation
this will not be an opportunity for us
to make excuses but rather to
investigate this case to the fullest to
provide the justice we all seek for a
tatiana our officer-involved shootings
are investigated by both our major case
unit which investigates the criminal
aspect of the case and our internal
affairs unit which investigates
administrative policy and training
violations these investigations can
occur concurrently but separately I will
outline where we are with both both
investigations at this point the
Internal Affairs Unit responded to the
scene of the shooting their role is to
observe the on-scene investigation but
they take a backseat to the criminal
investigation being conducted by the
Major Case unit the officer who shot at
Tatiana was served his written
administrative complaint on Sunday at
that time he was also placed on detached
duty the stripped of his badge and
firearm my intent was to meet with him
today to terminate his employment with
the Fort Worth Police Department
however the officer tendered his
resignation this morning before we met
even though we no longer works for the
city we will continue the administration
investigation as if he did the case will
be completed and reviewed by the chain
of command had the officer not resigned
it would have fired him for violations
of several policies including our use of
force policy our de-escalation policy
and unprofessional conduct a statement
of that effect will be placed within the
investigation to serve as a written
record of that determination
additionally the separation paperwork
that is sent to the state licensing
agency the Texas Commission on law
enforcement will reflect that he was
dishonorably discharged from employment
with the Fort Worth Police Department
now that the officer has resigned he's
no longer he no longer has the
protections of state civil service law
therefore I can now release his name
Aaron Dean ID four five nine eight was
the officer who responded to the call
and fired the shot that killed a tatiana
he was hired by the department on August
21st night 2017 and commissioned as a
licensed peace officer on April 13 2018
despite his resignation the officer
still faces criminal charges from the
major case investigation I personally
checked on the progress of that case
repeatedly and I anticipate a
substantial update to provide you no
later than tomorrow additionally we have
also presented a preliminary case to the
FBI to review the officer's actions for
possible civil rights violations none of
this information can ease the pain of a
Tatiana's family but I hope it shows the
community that we take these incidents
seriously we will continue to provide
updates as they become available thank
you
as stated by both mayor price and chief
Krause
my thoughts and prayers got to miss
Jefferson's family itani his death
should not have happened and on behalf
of the city of Fort Worth I am truly
sorry the community is called for
independent review of the police
department I would like to take a minute
to provide an update on our process to
bring on an Independent Police monitor
and that was a recommendation by the
race and culture task force and approved
by the City Council through the city's
recently adopted budget we're on track
to having candidates for the position in
Fort Worth for interviews in November as
part of the process we were working on
having a third party group of national
experts come in to review current police
policies and training practices to
ensure best practices are in place as
the monitor begins his or her work the
city manager's office will take the lead
in this effort and of course it will
include the participation of the police
department currently we are reaching out
to experts in the field and once we
finalize our plan and recommendation
we'll be presenting that to the City
Council in the next few weeks thank you
questions
come in and actually investigate the
shooting not just the policies within
this I have reached out to the Texas
Rangers and we discussed that however at
this point they have not committed to to
anything bringing them in this late
after the investigation started is not
ideal
you
I would say it the only time that would
be okay is if you knew that was the only
person in there and they were actively
firing upon you at the time as we've
been releasing video and trying to do it
quicker that is something we've done in
the past system to include the
photograph of the firearm to show what
the perceived threat may have been in
hindsight it was 20 it was it was a bad
thing to do I think it was to show that
there was a weapon involved
however we're homeowners in the state of
Texas I can't imagine most of us if we
thought we had somebody outside our
house they shouldn't be and we had
access to a firearm that we wouldn't act
very similarly to how she acted I I
don't have that information to comment
it was located just inside the window so
what was the instinct I don't know what
the disciplinary action on that but
definitely we need to review what we did
why we did that and and when it's
appropriate when it's not appropriate I
will have an update for you tomorrow on
the Criminal Investigation
the officers do not know if that Kate if
that call came in do not when one or
non-emergency they both go to the same
dispatcher an open structure call is
something that you would typically Park
down the street and approach cautiously
welfare check is something that doesn't
require quite a heightened response that
appears to be accurate patrol there's no
indication they knocked on the front
door and yes they get fired from the
back yard if they were doing a welfare
check yes if they thought they had
something more criminal and a more
tactical response would be warranted I
believe there was an accident on his
record and nothing else a traffic
accident
no she's being treated as a witness
officer
aaro in de aiken again it depends on the
mindset of the officer what type of call
they think they're responding to
absolutely each of these incidents
causes us to reflect upon that so we've
all but we've already had our use of
force coordinator lookout in other
agencies what they're doing their
training and their policies and compare
our so there and see where we need to
improve additionally we are accredited
texas police chiefs Association agency
and so they review policies annually as
well I do not have that information as
AJ I do not believe he has been with
another agency I tell them I get it I
nobody looked at that video and said
there's any doubt that this officer
acted inappropriately it I get it
we're trying to train our officers
better we're trying to shore up our
policies and we're trying to ensure that
they act and react the way that the
citizens intend them to they act and
react with a servant's heart instead of
a warrior's heart
there are times for officers to act as
warriors and defenders and there are
times that were them to act as public
servants and humble servants
community members last night individual
raised the number of shootings that have
happened officer-involved shootings and
important work in the area is there a
problem has something changed is there I
guess difference in responses now no
there's not enough alleviate had less
officer-involved shootings this year
than we did last year
we did have several in a short period of
time I believe six fatal ones since June
first which officer he resigned before
his opportunity to cooperate that is
correct I would I wouldn't say that's
why he was fired
[Music]
like I said I served him his
administrative written administrative
warning Sunday once that is served by
state state civil service law he has 48
hours to offer statement or we cannot
and cannot question him for 48 hours
after that point most of the officers
I've encountered over the past couple
days are telling me chief this isn't how
we operate they understand the gravity
of the situation they understand how
this has eroded the public trust in them
where it takes them longer to be public
that essentially gives them time to wipe
social media white beneath anything like
that clean and stepping up steps been
taken to preserve all of that in this
particular officers case and we saw in
the network Eiger case that ended up
being a significant issue in her trial
have steps been taken to preserve this
officers social media
I don't have that information I'm not
gonna comment former chief Fitzgerald I
think it's an unnecessary distraction
from the hurting community we accepted
the recommendations of race and cultural
task force and one of the charges to the
police monitor will be to look at best
practices for the CRB the citizens
Review Board and to recommend counsel
how it should be set up and how what
powers they should have and what their
authority will be so when the police
monitors hired they don't they one of
the first things he does is begin the
process to collect data on that this
panel that we're looking at is separate
from the police monitor the police
monitor is a part of our race and
cultural task force the panel was in
place to begin looking at use of force
training in all the processes within the
police department
[Music]
I could only reiterate what the chief
said that he has talked with the FBI in
case there's a civil rights violation
he's also gun to the Texas Rangers it's
my understanding they owe an answer back
but they were not inclined chief is that
what you'd say to take it at this point
the FBI is still looking at it they
haven't declined or in art cept it
either way
Brendan thank y'all very much for coming
here today I hope we've answered a lot
of your questions I will have the Chiefs
statement on our media portal within
half an hour think they would like a
copy of that I believe 9 sir but I'm all
we're gonna end it here if you have any
other questions you can email us at the
at our media address okay thank you very
much